I'm weird Barbie I am in the splits I
have a funky haircut and I smell like
basement oh my God I
eat yeah you did we had Bobby as
unfortunately the result of what happens
when kids play with their Barbies too
hard she has colored drawings on her
face her hair has been cut apart and
even burned a bit and worst of all she's
stuck during the splits and forced to
live in a Twisted Dream House on a hill
away from the rest of the Barbies we had
Bobby's eccentric personality as a
result of her being twisted and
contorted by kids throughout the years
we and Bobby is truly treated like a
leper in Barbie land and most of the
Barbies only go to see her to feel
better about themselves however weird
Barbie ends up being the reason that the
Barbies reclaimed Bobby land as she
helps put together a Revolt along with
some discontinued Barbies and a couple
of old cans weird Barbie helps rally
together the Barbies and concoct a plan
to save Barbie land from the Cairns by
the end the weird Barbie gained a
recognition and respect of the other
Barbies and is now seen as a true Barbie